i'm cole sprouse and this is the wired
auto complete interview
let's make me really nervous with these
who call sprouse
that's what i google when i google this
stuff who did cole sprouse play zach or
cody this one's still hard for me too i
get uh two residual paychecks every time
they air an old episode dylan sprouse
has been scrubbed from uh the history of
the show in an attempt to garner even
more financial revenue i've decided to
adopt and say i'm both no but i did play
cody
i'm pretty sure who did cole sprouse
play in big daddy i played a character
named julian i was the small son of the
big daddy so to speak who is older dylan
or cole sprouse my brother is older by
15 minutes which he has wielded over my
head like a weapon
for time immemorial who is cole
sprouse's best friend oh so you want to
start a war right now i would probably
say dylan is my best friend um and
that's the most politically uh correct
answer
when did cole sprouse start acting
cole sprouse started acting if you could
call it that at eight months old diaper
commercials were the first thing that my
twin and i did for those that are
unfamiliar identical twins work quite
well in acting
especially as young children or babies
because child labor laws dictate kids
can only work a certain amount of hours
but when there's two of them that look
exactly the same you double your
production time little economic loophole
right here that's the most american
thing ever
when did cole sprouse start photography
probably around 18 years old after the
suite life on deck my brother and i
applied to college um and we would end
up getting into nyu which was wonderful
but we deferred for a year and traveled
and i said you know what i want to take
a camera around with me and start then i
traveled for archaeology and i was doing
sort of documentary work and then one
day i
walked into conde nast with a buttoned
up shirt on and talked to traveler
magazine and said hey can i work for you
guys and they said not for money but you
can
like take a story and we'll i guess
maybe think about publishing it and i
said okay so then i took a train trip
from the west coast to the east coast of
the united states and i documented it
and
they put it on digital
which was incredibly exciting for me at
the time when did cole sprouse dye his
hair the truth is
i've had highlights in my hair since i
was a small child i know that luxurious
blonde bowl cut that you used to see on
disney channel lo and behold it wasn't
perfectly real that's movie magic baby i
changed my hair
according to the rolls if i
think a certain hair color might fit a
character better i do that i dyed my
hair for riverdale when i got the role
of jughead um and he is a character who
has black hair in the comic it's like an
article clothing it changes how i want
it but my natural is blonde for anyone
wondering uh when did cole sprouse first
appear in riverdale first episode
believe it or not but at the time i
didn't think jughead was going to be too
strong of a presence on the show the
pilot was kind of a story between um the
love triangle characters betty archie
and veronica and jughead was sort of a
silent observer but he was also the
narrator and i thought that was going to
be a bit more the role but as the show
got picked up um my character's presence
increased and now it's like uh
the four amigos
can i meet cole sprouse no
what's cold sprouts in game of thrones
nope
what did cole sprouse major in i majored
in something called geographical
information systems and applied it to
archaeology my grandfather was a
geologist so i had become fascinated
with the earth sciences archaeology is a
very interdisciplinary field of study so
it involves a ton of really really
interesting disciplines i got to explore
i got to travel i got to meet
interesting people how well do you know
cole sprouse man sometimes i stay awake
at night asking myself that same
question i think i know cole pretty well
but coal is always growing man
cole's changing too
just like you and don't be afraid of the
change come along
what cole sprouse what cole sprouse
what do you want
love what color are cole sprouse's eyes
on my driver's license it says green but
they kind of change from a bluish to a
more greenish hue depending on if i'm uh
overjoyed with my mortal experience
green is usually the color of joy and
blue
is the color of existential dread what
is cole sprouse's zodiac sign it's leo
okay what camera does cole sprouse use
i'll never tell you and because i think
the camera thing it's a it's a crutch
it's a game of big guns right everyone's
all concerned about the gun you're
wielding and no one's concerned about
actually just developing the eye of it
you know what i use i use a hello kitty
disposable camera from the thrift store
start with that one it's gonna look good
no but i started on a canon ae1 it's a
student's film camera it is film however
so there's a bit of an expenditure there
what languages does cole sprouse speak
english very well very poor italian and
then for some reason i took two to three
years of ancient latin which one cannot
speak
because it's a dead language though it
has helped me uh in my understanding of
other romantic or latinate languages and
that siren is coming from me
is cold sprouts emo
i had a big emo phase when i was younger
for sure eyeliner straightened my hair
when i was like
seven
i had a hair metal phase and i wore like
a leather jacket and chains and painted
my nails black and i thought it was so
cool i was seven is cold sprouts alive
um on the outside
it's cold sprouts italian by birth right
i suppose is cole sprouse related to
daisy ridley no uh we get that a lot i
understand we look similar but i already
have a twin
does cole sprouse
does cold sprouts have a sister no does
cold sprouts run instagram for netflix
maybe
does cole sprouse have any tattoos no i
really fear the makeup trailer it's like
yeah five to 15 minutes for every tattoo
does cold sprouts sing
sometimes
pay me
how
is cole sprouse how how just how is he
thank you first off for asking me that
i'm good right now i'm really good i'm
turning 30 soon how many movies has cole
sprouse been in back before uh social
media and the death of blockbuster my
brother and i did a lot of direct dvd
movies moonshot would be my third big
role in a movie big daddy five feet
apart and moonshot but i've done a a
host of direct-to-dvds how to tell the
difference between cole and dylan
sprouse i don't know the way that most
people have told the difference between
us is that i'm funny and he's not he's a
little more muscular he's currently got
a beard in terms of twins some identical
twins are very difficult to tell apart
and some are not so difficult and i find
that my brother and i if you spend about
an hour to two hours with us you can
figure it out pretty quick how to draw
cole sprouse step by step i like to
start with the ass cheeks and then i go
to the toes i sort of just jump from the
ass cheeks to the toes uh and then you
kind of connect whatever you want in
there let's continue shall we
cole sprouts beard cold sprouts beard is
that what they googled
i can grow one now it just takes a
little while cole sprouse podcast yes i
did a podcast with uh a production
company called q code which uh is a
story that started on the no sleep
subreddit um so if you want to check it
out it's called brasca it's a little
spooky though so um gerd your loins cole
sprouse best quote i don't know do i
decide that i'm the guy that decides
that i did hear one the other day i
wouldn't call it my best quote but it's
good if you meet three [ __ ] in a day
you're the [ __ ] keep that one with
you remember that and be nice everybody
cole sprouse you're watching disney
channel
that's it we're done we're done thank
you for searching and thank you for
watching i'm cole sprouse
that's it